un gesto público para transmitir
confianza el presidente electo joe biden
recibió la primera de las dos dosis de
la vacuna contra el hobbit 19
desarrollada por facer y bayonne tec
el líder demócrata defendió la seguridad
de las inmunizaciones
estoy haciendo esto para demostrar que
la gente debería estar preparada para
recibir la vacuna cuando esté disponible
no hay nada de que preocuparse el
próximo mandatario estadounidense
reconoció la tarea del gobierno saliente
de donald trump para lograr el rápido
desarrollo de los fármacos y llamó a los
ciudadanos a mantenerse alerta esto va a
tomar tiempo espero que la gente escuche
a todos los expertos al doctor fauci
hablando sobre la necesidad de usar
mascarillas durante las fiestas de
navidad y año nuevo también mantener la
distancia social y si no tienes que
viajar no lo hagas
por otro lado comenzó la administración
de la vacuna de moderna la segunda
aprobada en el país en trabajadores de
la salud para ello es la medida alimenta
la esperanza quiero que la gente se
sienta tranquila recibiendo la vacuna
sabiendo que está bien
vacuna es segura este es un momento de
esperanza para mí y para mis colegas y
los pacientes que tratamos estoy
deseando volver con suerte a lo que
conocemos como normalidad según las
autoridades unos 3.700 centros de salud
recibirán cerca de 35 millones de dosis
de la vacuna de moderna entre lunes y
martes una distribución mucho más amplia
que la de facer debido a que el fármaco
de modernas se conserva con mayor
facilidad